So, the Spring Approach to building operating system is to build strong
interfaces for each sub-system. What that means is, the only thing that is
exposed outside a sub-system is what services are provided by
the sub-system but not how. In other words, the how part of it can be changed at
any time, so long as the external interface remains
unchanged. So that is what is meant by strong
interfaces, and this naturally leads to object orientation.
And they also wanted to make sure that the
system is open and flexible. And this is
important if you're an operating system vendor and you
want to integrate third party software into your
operating system. You want to make sure that your
interfaces are open and flexible and at the same
time, you want to maintain the integrity of your
subsystems, and that's why strong interfaces are extremely
important. And being open and flexible also suggests
that you don't want everything to be written
in one language. You don't want to be tied
to a particular language for implementing all the
system components, and this is the reason that in
Spring they chose to use IDL, which is
the interface definition language, and this is from the
OMG group. There are IDL compilers that
are available from several third party software vendors,
and what that allows you to do is, you can define your interfaces using IDL.
And third party software vendors can use
that IDL definition of the interfaces and use
them in building their own subsystems that can
integrate with the Spring system. And the other
part of a Spring approach is extensibility
and extensibility naturally leads to microkernel based approach
and that's what you see here. This is
the structure of the Spring system and what
you see below this red line is Spring's idea of a microkernel and in fact there
are two parts to it. There is a nucleus, which in Spring is the entity that
provides the abstractions of threads and interprocess communication among
the threads. And the kernel itself is made up
of nucleus plus the virtual memory manager. So if
you have put these two things together, the nucleus
gives you threads and IPC and the VM manager
gives you memory management. And if you remember back
to our good old friend Liedtke's principle of what
a microkernel should provide. You see that what is below
this red line is exactly Liedtke's principle
that is the microkernel is providing the abstraction
of threads in IPC and an abstraction
of memory. And everything else is outside the
kernel. All the things that are above the red line are outside the kernel, and,
in particular, I mention that Spring is Sun
Microsystems' answer to building a network operating system.
Because this is a time when transitioning was happening
to services that are being provided on the network.
And so, they wanted to go from an operating
system that runs on a single node to a
network operating system using the same interface. Namely the
Unix interface, and so this entity that you see
here, which is called the network proxy. We'll see
that, more of it, in later discussion in this lesson.
This is the entity that allows machines to be
connected to one another. All the ovals that you're
seeing that are outside the kernel provide different services
that you might need in your desktop environment. For
instance an X11 server is a display manager and
you may need ability to do shell level programming,
and you need file system, and you need a
way by which you can communicate in the network,
meaning that you need a protocol stack.